okay when the call to prayer sounds
during training Ronaldo asked the coach
to PS to pause the session until it
finishes look how the respect he has
Subhan Allah Abdullah explained in the
beginning I was close to Cristiano
because he wasn't familiar with the
country's culture the club or other
aspects he was curious and often asked
me questions about certain details
according to Abdullah Ronaldo has always
been interested in converting to Islam
before his moved to anas in the winter
of 2023 reports suggested that his
former real former Real Madrid teammate
M let's let's we then we should talk
about us and if we're talking about us
we need to talk about growth they talk
about you what they should talk about
both it's easier to hate now and harder
to care we used to offer help now we
gossip and stare comment like swipe
share hate used to be rare now you see
it
every Salam alikum guys so don't forget
to check out cn.com guys use my discount
code and get beautiful clothes modest
clothes for your brothers sisters
aunties uncles whoever is for that
matter in check them out in c.com you
love it now let's get straight into in
Ral do we've heard a lot of rumors he's
been doing SJ there's other rumors he's
joined the Saudi football club um and
obviously this doesn't mean he's going
to accept Islam but he lives in the
country so Islam is bound to have an
impact on him and I'm going to read you
guys the article of the goalkeeper the
ex goalkeeper of the football club who
has leaked this information and this is
actually official this is actually
coming from him that he is very very
close except in Islam and this is really
profound you know why because it shows
you environment has a key factor in
these things because this is what he
said let's read for ourselves in brother
and sisters yeah so this this is what it
said W Abdullah reveals surprising
Insight on Cristiano Ronaldo's potential
conversion to
Islam um in the heart of Saudi Arabia
where football and Faith inter inter
intertwin Whispers have begun begun to
circulate about Cristiano Ronaldo's
spiritual journey Marakesh wed Abdullah
the former goalkeeper of anasa Al nasar
has made some striking statements
regarding Superstars Cristiano Ronaldo
the team's captain and and the
possibility of his conversion to Islam
speaking as a guest on the program Al
Abdullah confirmed long-standing rumors
about Ronaldo's open open list of
converting citing his clear inter
integration and adaptation to the Saudi
Arabian culture Ronaldo genuinely what
he said Ronaldo genuinely wants to
convert to Islam I spoke to him about it
and he expressed interest he has already
prostrated in the field after scoring
and has always encouraged the players to
pray and follow Islamic religious
practices said the former Saudi Saudi
International Abdullah went on to
explain that Ronaldo has taken a deep
interest in local culture especially
Islam and its practices in order to
better respect and understand his Muslim
teammates demonstrating a great deal of
kindness towards the Portuguese star
towards the uh towards them the
Portuguese star has ensured that his
teammates have time to pray between
training and training sessions Abdullah
shared more insight in christano
Ronaldo's growing interest in Islam
revealing how the superstar has shown
respect for Islamic practices since his
arrival arrival in Saudi Arabia and we
all know that he's always had that
before um from the get-go okay when the
call to prayer sounds during training
Ronaldo asked the coach to PS to pause
the session until it finishes look how
the respect he has Subhan Allah Abdullah
explained in the beginning I was close
to Cristiano because he wasn't familiar
with the country's culture the club or
other aspects he was curious and often
asked me questions about certain details
according to Abdullah Ronaldo has always
been interested in converting to Islam
before his moveed to an nasar in the
winter of 2023 reports suggested that
his former real former Real Madrid
teammate mid oil which is a Turkish
Muslim uh individual and kareim Bena I
think he Moroccan had tried to convince
him to becoming a Muslim the former anas
goalkeeper pointed out particularly tell
telling moment when Ronaldo prostrated
on the field after scoring all the
players shouted allahar in un however
Abdullah added
to that regardless of whether Ronaldo
decides to embrace Islam his discipline
and commitment as a player are
unquestionable he is extremely
disciplined and dedicated player and
it's the discipline that has brought him
to this position he said Abdullah also
spoke about Ronaldo's humility nothing
but nothing that both sorry noting that
both he and his son behave in Simplicity
and warmth towards others anyone who
comes to Saudi Arabia appreciates him
and feels comfortable with him he added
now guys Subhan Allah isn't that amazing
isn't that profound Subhan Allah and you
know there's key factors in this which
is what your surroundings like wherever
you are hearing the aan seeing the
people people look at your actions bro I
have non-muslim family members people
look at your AC they don't care about
what you can recite how good you speak
how much you can call they don't care
what you wear F beard means zero to them
because the moment they see a and I'm
saying you know whoever it is for that
matter or a brother in a for et make a
mistake what do they say ah there you go
this is the problem guys so it's so
important for us to make sure I know
we're not perfect but at least don't do
certain stuff you're wearing jbab hijab
don't go sitting on men's laps don't be
kissing guys I don't is your husband
yeah okay if you're a brother you know
you got you know in a fob Etc you don't
really see this you know moving around
with girls but I don't know whatever
you're doing smoking drinking whatever
the hell you're doing brother you're a
representation yes your uniform plays a
big role this is very important and not
only that what does Allah subh say in
the Quran inah Bak Allah says in inah
Bak five five beautiful verses that I
want to read to you guys brother and
sisters yeah Allah says in the Quan
Al
[Music]
now what does Allah subhana tala say in
the
Quran Yep this is the book there is no
doubt about it a guide for those who are
mindful of Allah who believe in the
Unseen establish prayer and donate from
what we have provided for them and and
who believe in what has been revealed to
you oh prophet and what was revealed
before for you and have sure faith in
the
Hereafter it is they who are truly
Guided by the Lord and it is they who
will be successful brother and sisters
so Subhan Allah this is a message inshah
for you guys and also to Ronaldo if he
accept hislam make to offer him and
Subhan Allah brother and sisters if you
are watching this if you're not a Muslim
we Islam is open to anybody we do we are
not like Judaism or you know whatever it
is that you need to strict protocol you
can't be a to whatever as a Muslim it is
open for everybody especially the
Sinners especially the Sinners it is for
them to purify their hearts it is for
them and they are truly successful and
they are the ones that are truly guided
if you are watching this and you want to
embrace Isam do not let it stop you I
accepted Islam 11 years ago yes after
doing like 14 years before that I was
doing um well 14 years ago about two and
a half years three years looking into
the religion so brothers and sisters if
you're watching this if you are close to
Islam embrace it and we ask Allah
subhana T to guide Ronaldo because the
prophet Muhammad peace upon would always
go for people of influence and give them
da can you imagine the impact of Ronaldo
coming to Isam what it could do so
brothers and sisters this shows us our
character the way we behave is Da so
Ronaldo is observing this in Saudi
Arabia he lives there he's observing
this and I believe this plays the key
factor and not only that you can see the
goodness in his heart just imagine what
kind of an amazing person he would be
further by accepting Islam and just to
knowe brothers and sisters somebody
might look at Ronaldo and say look he's
he does goodness Etc but the greatest
goodness is the one that has and fixes
his relation with God Almighty and
believes in Allah and the final
messenger the prophet and accepts Islam
inah other than that we believe that
anyone who could be a saint in the world
to everybody but does not accept Islam
knowing knowing knowing this the
condition knowing Islam is the truth he
will enter the fire and that is our
religion because the one who knows Islam
is the truth and doesn't accept it shows
that he's taken his desire like Allah
says in the Quran have you seen the one
who takes his desire as his own God so
for those who are watching make dualo I
believe we are going to get the news in
of him accepting Islam may Allah subhana
guide him Islam doesn't need him rather
he needs Islam it's just we're happy
that someone like him who has an amazing
heart who's done a video for the syrians
for the Palestinians Allah subhana will
guide him brother and sisters and I'll
end on this note anytime you have
goodness in your heart and you do this
stuff brother sisters where you try to
good to other people and whatever it is
for that matter when Allah sees goodness
that's why Allah says we do not guide
the wrongdoing people so when you have
goodness in your heart Allah subhana wa
tala sees that and give him charity do
good stuff Allah will guide you and I
believe this plays a key factor insh in
Ronaldo ex Islam till next
time do not forget to check out s.com
use my discount
code I know